madame monsieur bonjour et merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur le plateau de la
voie est libre en bourgogne la semaine
politique a été chargée entre le vote à
l'assemblée nationale sur la révision
constitutionnelle le départ de laurent
fabius du gouvernement le remaniement
ministériel qui a suivi avec le retour
de jean marc ayrault et des écologistes
et puis l'intervention jeudi soir du
président de la république à la
télévision de quoi alimenter le débat
que nous allons avoir ce matin avec
cécile untermaier bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député socialiste de saône et loire
est depuis mercredi juste présidente de
la commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale alain suguenot bourgeot je
vous êtes député maire de beaune les
républicains stéphanie modde bonjour
porte-parole régional d'europe écologie
les verts et vous êtes adjointe au maire
de dijon
enfin julien houle ou bonjour bonjour
vous êtes conseiller régional de
bourgogne franche comté élus du front
national alors commençons par leur
remaniement annoncé jeudi après-midi il
est marqué donc par le retour de jean
marc ayrault et aussi par l'entrée de
trois écologistes dont emmanuel coste
qui dirigeait jusqu'à lors le parti
europe ecologie les verts alors le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que ce
gouvernement il annonce de ce
gouvernement n'a pas suscité vraiment
beaucoup d enthousiasme je me tourne
vers vous sessegnon temps meilleurs vous
l'êtes vous enthousiaste non mais moi je
suis résolu à ce que ce gouvernement
travaille bien et répondent aux
interrogations et aux attentes des
citoyens donc que je souligne quand même
et qui est pour moi extrêmement
intéressant c'est l'entrée de trois
écologistes au sein du gouvernement
je pense que cette entrée peut aussi
changer la proche des choses et porter
quand même cette rénovation politique
dans la façon de travailler à laquelle
je tiens énormément et je saluerai bien
sûr là la mise en place d'un secrétaire
d'état à la biodiversité alors à y
revenir avec vous bien sûr d'abord alain
suguenot un mot j'ai vu votre réaction
vous ce remaniement ne donne aucune
réponse aux inquiétudes des français
avez vous écrit dans l'europe
nick est question était une bonne
réponse je suis pas en tout cas ce fait
là sûrement pas puisque concrètement
j'ai vu qu'un de vos confrères
éditorialistes avait qualifié françois
hollande de monsieur bricolage
je crois que là on est vraiment au fond
de la boîte à outils je peux incarner
dans un concept où on a voulu faire
éclater le mouvement écologiste en
faisant les diligences nécessaires et
enfin d'un gouvernement
les uns et les autres jean marc ayrault
vient je pensais que le héros était
fatigué mais maintenant il revient et je
pense que oui mais comme il n'a pas pu
avoir le perchoir ce que bartolone a été
battu aux élections régionales on est à
ce niveau là donc c'est vrai que c'est
pas avant d'avis que l'attendent des
françaises et les français c'est parce
qu'ils attendent aux agriculteurs
aujourd'hui en colère c'est pas ce
qu'attendent les chômeurs sais pas ce
qu'ils attendent du jeune je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans tous les cas c'est
pas le meilleur moyen c'est une cuisine
électorale tout le monde est convaincu
je vais dire je crois dans la réaction
mais c'est pas top chef
mes collègues disait récemment qu'ils
avaient cauchemar en cuisine j'ai peur
que ce soit un petit peu ça aujourd'hui
c'est un dollar
j'ai passé de la cuisine en tout cas les
très mauvaises et puis le malheur fait
que ce sont les français qui la goutte
tous les jours et pour le moins les
saumâtre ce remaniement il est marqué
par le néant
c'est à dire que françois hollande a
fait rentrer l'incompétence a fait
rentrer et l'arrivisme et à faire entrer
les chèques dans son gouvernement qu'est
ce qu'on constate finalement du
recyclage d'anciens dinosaures donc de
la politique de gauche donc jean marc
ayrault en échec total donc dans le
début du quinquennat
jean michel baylet jean michel baylet
donc qui qu'a éclaté quand même été
ministre en 1988 sous mitterrand et qui
revient donc après avoir perdu son
département en 2015 qui connaît bien les
territoires et rosie les maires de lot
tout ça c'est de la de la cuisine
politique uniquement pour faire le vide
à gauche donc pour sa candidature en
mais en rien répondre aux attentes et
aux préoccupations des français
de toute façon on sait bien c'est pas
une question de personnes c'est pas une
question d'homme ou de femme
le véritable remaniement qui apportera
un réel changement c'est le changement
de politique est le vrai remaniement
celui qu'attendent les français c'est
quand marine le pen en mai 2007
reconduire à françois hollande à sa
voiture sur peyron d'élise et là on aura
un réel remaniement et un salaire pour
l'aca
la salle avec prochaine stéphanie modde
alors sa volée et la zizanie après cette
annonce la zizanie au sein de votre
parti est ce que vous faites partie de
ceux et de celles qui regrette l'entrée
d'emmanuel coste dans ce gouvernement
pourrait tout à fait sincère c'est vrai
que je me suis même demandé ce que je
pouvais venir apporter ici ce matin
comme parole du fait effectivement de la
situation que traverse actuellement mon
parti politique d'europe écologie les
verts
bon je ne pratique pas la chaise vide
donc je suis bien évidemment présentes
mais si frémit effectivement extrêmement
désagréable pour moi comme ça l'a été
pour l'ensemble des porte paroles de mon
mouvement d'avoir à justifier l'an près
d'une personne qui s'est présentée seule
qui a été contacté seul sans aucun
contact entre partis politiques comme
serveur aurait dû se faire pour
permettre l'entrée des écologistes
europe écologie au gouvernement donc ce
n'est pas europe écologie qui est ouvert
mais parce qu'on peut préciser elle a
reçu un communiqué le matin m un ton
grave europe ecologie les verts
n'avaient pas eu de contact nous n'avons
pas eu de contact nous n'avons pas
l'impression ou voire même par rapport
il n'ya pas d'ailleurs de nouveau
programme politique effectivement y'a
pas de bouleversements politiques sur
les la dernière année qui va venir
donc nous n'avions de toute façon pas
les conditions nécessaires pour rentrer
de nouveau dans ce gouvernement
sur les trois écologistes y en a deux
qui sont partis il ya maintenant un an
du mouvement c'est elle qui fera avec
toujours écologistes qui se revendique
écologiste n'est pas du mouvement europe
ecologie les verts donc effectivement il
ya des entrées d'individus qui se remet
en dit et grand bien leur fasse
eh bien je pense effectivement qu'il ya
des vraies compétences mais nous aurions
préféré bien évidemment voir une
véritable discussion programmatique et
de toute façon les conditions
actuellement ne sont pas réunies quand
on voit ce qui se passe par rapport aux
annonces
évidemment on va me dire notre dame des
landes très bien mais y avait pas besoin
de ça d'avoir des entrées des
écologistes pour que notre dame des
landes soit reposée sur la tam
les propositions que faisait madame
royal ou parisien plus apportent
intéressante que un simple référendum
pour l'instant on ne connaît pas
d'ailleurs les tenants et les
aboutissants en faisant croire par
position mais pour l'instant donc avait
pas besoin de ça et de toute façon je le
répète les conditions actuelles nous ne
permettent pas à l'écologie politique de
s'exprimer dans ce gouvernement
vous pensez avec trois nouveaux
écologistes malgré tout dans le goût
ernement ça peut pas être un plus pour
prendre en contre justement les
préoccupations environnementales
nicolas hulot a eu la proposition d'un
très beau ministère
il l'a refusée que propose-t-on aux
trois écologistes présents pas ce
ministère c'était ministère de
l'ecologie de l'énergie transports
madame royal voilà donc là ça risque
était proposé à nicolas hulot on ne
propose pas ça aux personnes qui ont
souhaité rentrer d'elle même dans ce
gouvernement
donc non je pense que malheureusement et
malgré toutes les qualités personnelles
des uns et des autres j'entends bien
effectivement sur la biodiversité yann
moix sur la biodiversité qu'on attend
depuis un certain moment
si elle aboutit tant mieux je veux dire
je suis pas dans la politique du pire
bien évidemment si nous arrivons à
avancer sur la biodiversité
on a en tout cas actuellement l'épandage
de boues rouges dans la méditerranée
qu'en été actée par chrome in iz contre
l'avis de la ministre de l'environnement
donc ça c'est pas un progrès donc j'ai
les plus grands doutes je leur fait
bon courage mais je pense que c'est un
leurre ces deux-là torrent de la
tactique à cenon écoutez je crois que je
vois pas comment on peut justifier ça
autrement je pense que ma collègue
socialiste dira le contraire mais il
n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui landais dans un
concept où les français restent cois 14
à 14 15 14 mois oyo 15 je suis persuadé
qu'à partir de dans un an tout le monde
sera en campagne électorale y compris le
président de la république se serait tu
pollues final je crois que c'est ce qui
est prévu aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
préparé pour reparler de cuisine
électorale
je me mets à la place aujourd'hui mode
et c'est usant des écologistes très
honnêtement c'est une trahison
c'est un éclatement en plein vol donc
moment déterminé je pense qu'il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont créer
un ministère de l'égalité réelle égalité
elle existe ou n'existe pas l'égalité
réelle on cherche en trio trêve de
vocabulaire aujourd'hui des sauf
conduits pour essayer d'imaginer des
situations sadi a dit trahi et du
travail et c'est pas ses parents c'est
dommage d'avoir attendu quatre ans pour
recoller à l'égalité réelle très
honnêtement c'est fait partie du
vocabulaire du charabia condos
effectivement garantir une femme je
pense que vous n'êtes pas leur ipad sera
bien quand on parlera enfin quand on dit
également que la ministre aujourd'hui
des femmes celui des enfants ou un
massage fidèle je vous rejoins de la
qualification
cuisine
ericka bareigts steve a porté très fort
les gars je ne parle pas de la qualité
des candidats non mes fans c'est vrai
que la tarte qui ont été aujourd'hui
l'affichage de choses la qualité des
sciences et on a pris effectivement
notamment des nouveaux secrétaires
d'état de l'eau ministre n'a aucune
expérience fera que dans la période
actuelle
la véritable solution c'est comme
d'apporter des femmes et des hommes
d'expérience je ne critique pas monsieur
baylet et puisque on sait que il en
rêvait aussi mais c'est vrai que de voir
barbares ont pu rêver de ça vincent
placé on aime et on pourra y était
d'ailleurs placé gagnant leurs oeufs
dans le pied arrêtés ça y est on va
laisser finir tufnell père est
aujourd'hui très honnêtement je crois
que le vrai problème c'est pas celui là
vous savez bien qu'il françaises et les
français
les agriculteurs tout à l'heure sont
vraiment au bord de la crise de nerfs
ils ont même quelques fois dépassé cela
il attendait autre chose et je crains
jeudi comme je pense d'une salle
françois gendre pensait que quoiqu'il
soit d'études et verdir entre guillemets
son propos se donner l'image de
quelqu'un qui pouvait rapporter une
solution aux problèmes des français
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
évidemment le désenchantement total je
crains en tous les cas que cette année
soit une année difficile c'est une dent
may hambourg - s'entend sur le fait de
dire qu' il a cherché à élargir sa base
et les pauses qui doit paraître normal
il a élargi sa base électorale et puis
je pense que le problème si vous êtes
vous voulez du remaniement ministériel à
vous entendre on est chacun dans des
postures et je trouve que c'est un peu
ridicule c'est pas ce qu'attendent de
nous les français franchement le
remaniement ministériel
à mon avis c'est derrière eux déjà ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'on travaille sur le
terrain
absolument et moi ce que je fais je me
préoccupe pas du remaniement ministériel
ce que je fais en tant que député bien
occupée par exemple de la fermeture des
classes est ce que ça représente pour
des territoires ruraux
quand on ferme une école alors moi je
pense le remaniement ministériel c'est
bien on a fait nos commentaires d'usagé
met à jour dans le concret et répondons
d'abord avec un gouvernement tu dois
travailler différemment en relation
étroite avec notamment les par leurs
pairs allons allons allons vers le
terrain et vers les primes détention d
mais le remaniement ministériel avec ses
discours attendu sur la personne qui ne
devait pas rentrer sur celle qu'on voit
là les jeunes en somme
est ce qu'on sera vraiment vous aimeriez
que rien dans une communication
politicienne que n'attendent plus du
tout de la charité pardon qui a proposé
ce qui a provoqué ce remaniement c'est
pas effectivement l'arrière laurent
fabius déconsidère pas les ministres qui
sont là puis 2012 sur des postes
importants et je crois que il faut
cesser enfin de travailler de cette
façon là et au contraire ap faire parce
qu'on a une population qui est inquiète
actuellement alors n'ajoutons pas de la
culture elle c'est de la responsabilité
des politiques que de garder vers eux
des problèmes internes et au contraire
de forte vers les citoyens français
citoyens français politique et la
politique qu'ils attendent en matière de
2,2 d'accès aux soins en matière
d'égalité d'accès aux études en matière
d'égalité d'accès à l'enseignement avec
le problème notamment des fermetures de
classes qui nous profite pas pu alors
que c'est que ce référendum pour notre
dame des landes qui vient dé kribi lisez
vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir ce
que la justice peut faire aujourd'hui
quand monsieur le président de la
république disait encore récemment il a
pris un engagement clairement de dire
quand les recours seront terminés
effectivement rentrer a relevé du sujet
lear corp soit pas terminé on change la
donne on faire et faire 2 qui n'a
d'ailleurs aucune raison d'aboutir parce
qu'on ne se connaît pas son périmètre on
sait très bien que c'est pas une
solution juridique qui sera applicable
qui permettrait à l'issue du référendum
moi je la trouve intéressante vous
soulevez très justement la question des
vues suisse qui est passé devant
c'est vrai que ce référendum à mon sens
une règle du est fait avant dessus voilà
comme la grâce présidentielle frac c'est
pas le meilleur moyen de donner entre
guillemets de la justice une une option
qu'ils soient d'hommes à fait cohérent
pour les français
allez fernando référendum à la madame
mode après sur ce référendum
effectivement il y avait déjà aussi
effectivement le respect de ce qui est
actuellement en justice et à dire qu'il
ya des recours qui ne sont pas terminées
qui sont extrêmement importants qui sont
sur l'eau notamment
voilà donc si cercoux venait à aboutir
il n'y aura pas besoin de référendum
parce que vos projets sera totalement
abandonné donc déjà allons jusqu'au bout
de ces recours si un référendum
effectivement que cela n'aurait sa belle
dans le pays mais là effectivement on en
est au bout du bout ça fait des années
que ça dure ça eu des combats assez
violents qui ont opposé
donc là on se retrouve à quoi
effectivement s'il devait y avoir un
référendum
il faut effectivement les deux régions
concernées bretagne pays de la loire
soit voilà ce soit le bon périmètre
pour l'instant c'est que des
propositions que font mes collègues des
pays de la loire et de bretagne
il faut par contre aussi qu'il a vrai
débat public si ceux-ci se débat 6e
notre dame des landes s'est enlisé
depuis des années c'est que nous n'avons
pas de vrai débat public sur la question
de façon objective de façon rationnelle
qui ne met pas les uns en face les
autres des acteurs qui sont trop engagé
ce débat public -si n'a pas lieu le
référendum ne servir à rien nous aurons
des confrontations directes forcément un
débat non peut y avoir ça peut être quoi
ça peut être êtes vous pour ou contre
notre occupation
etes-vous pour ou contre alors on va
nous ressortir la question de l'emploi
que c'était aller les enclavement
en face qui seront là m on a plein de
choses à bangui n'est jamais un accident
il ya déjà de quoi développer de
mutualiser l'existant il ya déjà de
préserver des terres agricoles de très
bonne qualité il ya donc il faut qu'il
ya un vrai débat public et tout le monde
le comprenne
oui je ne devais pas sûr que ce soit ce
référendum le front national propose la
mise en place du référendum plus tout à
fait favorables aux consultations
j'irai locales les urnes favorable à ce
référendum je veux dire ce n'est pas du
tout au niveau des enjeux actuels
c'est à dire que c'est une petite
manoeuvre cosmétiques qui n'a rien
apporté si françois hollande vraiment
s'avère inférieur aux sommes qu'il les
fasse au niveau national mais sur des
sujets majeurs c'est à dire la politique
migratoire est ce que les français
peuvent se prononcer sur le fait qu'
encore un afflux de migrants
considérable notre pays un peu par
rapport à des chiffres est vital aussi
vous avez de nombreux villages de
petites communes qui reçoivent des
migrants tous les jours dans les
français ne supportent plus d'ailleurs à
cela une vie ne sais pas j'ai pas
traduit du 13e au sipal ont démissionné
qu'ils n'ont pas été informés
sabrina tout à fait vrai veineux ou il
ya une cinquantaine de migrants sont
arrivés sont partis ailleurs
y'a pas d'autres communes isolées enfin
c'est très peu par rapport à d'autres
pays non mais c'est très peu peut-être
par rapport à d'autres pays mais c'est
inadmissible pardon parce qu'ils les
montrent pas peur avec les migrants et
avec des chiffres qui s'en faut je crois
qu'on a une dans un mode vie politique à
dire la réalité des faits il n'y a pas
de migration 8 ans et vous évitez aussi
probablement que ce soit tout et
n'importe quoi va pas revenir sur ce
déballage parce que j'ai battu les deux
nuits il n'empêche faisons très
attention quand même y compris si on
veut éviter certains votes les appelle
de ses voeux
il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui gardons la
tête froide et évitons les jeunes
apporte quoi qu'on constate que
l'allemagne d'ailleurs elle même un
petit peu à travers la position de la
merkel ont engagé et aujourd'hui la
vraie solution à connaît depuis toujours
c'est le trouver comme des solutions à
la base évidemment on revient au niveau
de discussions sur la syrie et qui est
en train de se passer entre les états
unis et la russie
le drame c'est qu'aujourd'hui encore
notre diplomatie a encore échoué puisque
effectivement c'est à ce niveau là qu'il
disait à ce faux on a trop attendu à ce
niveau là il est aujourd'hui la
migration l'immigration on en est votre
grande partie responsables et les états
risquent d'être compliquées puisque
monsieur mèche et des phares redit ce
matin à 12h30 heure de retour dans la
guerre froide puisque juste terminée sur
le carillon
alors ce référendum ont ajouté un grand
référendum sur la politique migratoire
un référendum aussi sur le traité
transatlantique qui va totalement
sacrifier notamment des agriculteurs et
je vais revenir n'ont pas encore
totalement concluants
vous savez très bien les conséquences
vont être dramatiques et nous
agriculteurs le savent
je reviens sur les propos de madame la
députée qui parlait d'une population
inquiète c'est un euphémisme comme quand
vous voyez l'état de la france
actuellement avec 7 millions de chômeurs
10 millions de pauvres la cam 350000
pauvres en région bourgogne franche
comté c'est pas une population inquiète
c'est une population qui n'en peut plus
des français qui sont qui souffrent tous
les jours donc les petites politique
d'appareils les petites tactiques pour
s'assurer je dirais le soutien de la
gauche unie pour 2017 c'est vraiment pas
au niveau et des difficultés que
rencontrent nos compatriotes
allez on passe à autre chose à la
déchéance de nationalité le vote a lieu
mercredi à l'assemblée nationale si je
ne me trompe pas c'est si longtemps
meilleur vous avez voté contre hambourg
et d'ailleurs on peut préciser que seule
la député de la nièvre martine carrillon
couvreur et il le député de l'yonne jean
yves collet ont voté pour alors pourquoi
cette opposition de la gauche
moi j'ai pas j'ai voté contre l'article
2 on parle de l'article de 20 sur la
défense de schalke sur le projet de
révision constitutionnelle sur l'article
1 je considère que nous devons parce
qu'il ya débat là aussi là dessus je
considère que nous devons
constitutionnaliser l'état d'exception
que représente l'état d'urgence en
revanche sur l'article 2 j'ai voté
contre
après avoir beaucoup travaillé au sein
de la commission des lois a amélioré le
texte provenaient qui vous est d'une
façon exclusive les binationaux alors
moi j'ai deux arguments pour dire je ne
veux pas de l'article 2 c'est que en
tant que constituant puisque nous sommes
députés constituants
je considère que la constitution indique
à son article 34 que les règles
relatives à la nationalité sont du
domaine de la loi et je renvoie à la loi
est bien là cette question d'une
déchéance le cas échéant de nationalité
ou des attributs de la nationalité mais
je considère que dans la constitution
il n'y a pas de place pour la mention de
la déchéance de nationalité qui est elle
même avec la perte de nationalité
comprise dans cette notion de l'article
34 qui dit que la loi gère la question
de la nationalité donc c'est déjà une
question de principe importante parce
que
constitution c'est la loi fondamentale
et je ne souhaite pas dans ce pacte
social que constitue la constitution et
bien que nous introduisions une notion
qui est relative en fait un dispositif
pénal et qui trouvera toute sa place
dans une discussion beaucoup moins
crispé beaucoup plus beaucoup plus utile
au sein d'une loi avec le temps
nécessaire pour les députés à travailler
sur cette question tout à fait
fondamental alors assis nous vous
l'avons dit vous n'avez pas pris part au
vote
si je me suis abstenu non vous êtes
abstenu sur la révision
constitutionnelle mais pas le mercredi
sûr il ya une erreur de la santé a pris
part au vote lundi soir et j'ai goûté le
mercredi une abstention
elle avait d'ailleurs une abstention sur
l'ensemble du texte sur l'ensemble du
texte mais bien évident c'est bien sur
l'article 2 nous soumet en vote solennel
il y avait sur les deux articles
donc c'est très difficile de voter pour
l'un comme pour l'autre concrètement il
y en a certainement fait ça oui mais
comme je vois pas comment on peut sur le
plan juridique et le rang d'oignons
notamment il a voté contre l'article 2
mais justement il ya un vote je veux
dire de votre pas sur un article sinon
effectivement très revenir complètement
débat suédois jeudi j'assume
complètement cette abstention d'habitude
une absorption c'est pas très courageux
et là je l'aï su parce que je ne pense
pas qu'on pouvait voter contre cette
fois-ci par rapport aux symboles que
peut représenter effectivement la
nécessité aujourd'hui de sanctionner
ceux qui viennent aujourd'hui massacrer
des femmes des enfants d'une manière
complètement aveugle on ne peut pas
voter pour non plus je suis correspondre
d'accord avec ma collègue simplement
parce que sur le plan strictement
juridique
on n'a pas besoin d'une réforme
constitutionnelle et j'espère simplement
que le cdal dira vous savez que encore
avoir beaucoup à perdre sur ce dossier
là je pense que là aussi les françaises
et les français y avait autre chose à
attendre que trois mois de débats
stériles sur un dossier qui par essence
ne demande pas cette montagne la souris
est aujourd'hui que l'on perde encore
des mois qu'on sache si on va à
versailles ou pas on a eu également des
économies sur deux ans à faire y compris
dans nos assemblées
je pense que les françaises et les
français n'en peuvent mais ils ont assez
de ces débats là c'est un débat
juridique est la raison pour laquelle
sera qu'on pouvait pas voter contre ne
pouvaient pas voter pour me suis abstenu
j'espère simplement que la situation
sera clarifiée
je dis simplement que si on doit aller à
versailles bien évidemment je le voterai
contre sur le principe même cette fois
ci parce que la procédure
ne nécessiterait véritablement pas qu'on
perde encore autant de temps j'espère
qu'on n'ira pas à versailles
j'espère que le président de la
république qui a d'une manière un peu
malencontreuse évoqué cela qui se
retrouve un peu en face de sa parole
donnée cette fois ci également devant le
congrès et s'apercevra qu'on a peut-être
d'autres chats à fouetter en ce moment
avec les françaises et les français qui
vont mal voudrais pas qu'on compte il va
se bagarrer y compris dans ma famille
politique d'ampoulés partout et je
voulais pas non plus être au talent d'un
vote contre thériault de ma famille ou
d'un vote pour celui ci la liberté d'un
député république on va d'ailleurs aider
vraiment des clivages dans tous les
partis y compris chez les écologistes ça
y'en à sernhac l'a trahie quand même
qu'on votait pour cinq semaines pas les
autres ont voté contre mais nous sommes
quand même très majoritairement contre
je pense que si nous pouvons voter
contre ce projet de loi parce
qu'effectivement vous avez déjà évoqué
les uns les autres nous avons déjà les
outils institutionnels pour pouvoir
travailler sur la déchéance de la
nationalité
le souci principal de cette de cette
façon d'un scandale ternit le bleu le
dossier c'est quand même la défiance des
binationaux et le finalement le lait
puis d'égalité on est médecin nationale
puis dans le texte et puis dans le texte
mais je sais que la droite fait que ça
revienne donc si certains cas ce qu'on
va repartir ça va repartir sur un souci
donc ce débat n'est pas clos
effectivement il ya un moment pas été
posée mais qui ne va pas tenir
donc effectivement moi je serais pour
qu'on passe maintenant à des choses on a
déjà les outils institutionnels pour
travailler sur le sujet soit on est
français effectivement c'est une
véritable lutte contre cette
radicalisation contre ce terrorisme
donc faisons en sorte que les polices
déjà travail entre elles correctement
sérieusement alors voilà qu'est ce que
donnent les bords renseignements qu'on
arrête la guerre cette guerre de police
quitte pas ton absurde qu a priori nous
a fait perdre du temps donc là nous
sommes tout à fait conscients de
l'urgence de là mais nous avons déjà
tous les outils retravaillons sur la
politique de la ville retravaillons sur
cd france est vraiment attendre en
termes de deux ans qu'on arrivait enfin
à réduire ce chômage massif
quand je disais tout à l'heure que les
réunions équipe les raisons n'étaient
prêts nous n'avons pas raison de rentrer
dans cette de nous avons raison de ne
pas rentrer dans un gouvernement par non
parce que tout n'est pas mis en place
contre ce chômage massif il ya dix mois
des années que nous disons la transition
énergétique est un des moyens pour
pouvoir à la fois réduire notre facture
énergétique donc être moins dépendants
de l'étranger faire travailler des
personnes qualifiées on parle de plan
formation qualifions les personnes
relançons cette économie qui est
bénéfique pour tout le monde est pour
l'instant dans le projet de loi dans le
budget pardon 2016
l'airé les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour qu'on puisse enfin lancer
ce grand plan massif
je viens d'où je reviens sur la révision
constitutionnelle art les deux des
petites et front national ont voté
contre
tout à fait pourquoi vous avez je
voulais expliquer un peu la pression
pourquoi déjà moi ce qui m'attriste
danse dans ce débat c'est que les
barbares de l'état islamique doivent
rire quand il regarde un peu la
faiblesse de l'état français et quatre
mois de tapage et d'un puissant sur ce
débat c'est à dire qu'au sortir du 13
novembre qui nous a tous
frappez et toucher le président françois
hollande avait je dirais essayer de
rassembler la nation avec un discours
fort et consensuelle malheureusement il
en est sorti le néant voilà et quatre
mois après nous sommes toujours sur ce
débat pour une mesurette qui est
totalement vidée de son sens donc comme
l'ont dit mais mes collègues le député
comme l'ont fait savoir aussi nous
députés patriotes à l'assemblée
nationale oui comme la nationalité
appartient au domaine de la loi b sur
une simple réforme législative aurait
suffi pour adapter la déchéance de la
nationalité à cette nouvelle forme de
terrorisme perpétrés par dans l'état
islamique et sur l'état de la chance
vous êtes d'accord ça rentre dans la
constitution pour pau
a priori on nous dit que c'est pour
pouvoir encadrer cette mesure qui ne
neige pas survivre l'état d'urgence
quand on entend manuel valls on va
continuer l'état d'urgence et jusqu'à la
la fin de la guerre contre le terrorisme
islamiste c'est à dire qu'on va
continuer encore 20 ans avec l'état
d'urgence c'est moi c'est ce qui me
frappe c'est l'impuissance caractérisée
de ce gouvernement
voilà alors qu'il ya des réformes et des
mesures qui sont simples c'est retrouver
nos frontières nationales
c'est fermer les mosquées salafistes et
lutter véritablement contre le
communautarisme islamisme tout ça c'est
des décisions fortes mais que le
gouvernement ne prend pas de fermeture
il y aura d'autres attentats d'ampleur
en europe c'est une certitude c'est ce
qu'a déclaré ce matin manuel valls à
munich
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment mettre en
état d'urgence comme disait jules et
redouble à demeure finalement ratifié il
ya des confusions qui sont faites
c'est normal parce que c'est quand même
compliqué l'article 20 ne vise qu'à
constitutionnaliser un régime
d'exception vous avez dans la
constitution l'article 16
les pleins pouvoirs vous avez l'article
36 sur les assiège et vous avez
désormais c'est ce que moi je souhaite
avec beaucoup de mes collègues que
l'article que l'article va permette
l'inscription dans la constitution d'un
dispositif adapté à la situation que
nous rencontrons maintenant et qui va
quand même duré un certain temps et qui
s'appelle l'état d'urgence qui est un
régime dérogatoire au droit commun qui
implique des dispositifs de police qui
sont extraits
droit commun et qui mérite d'être
encadré de sorte que lorsque la loi
ensuite advient eh bien elle est elle
est prise dans les garanties apportées
par cet article et je précise une chose
c'est que par voie d'amendement nous
avons rajouté le contrôle parlementaire
lors on va mieux le contrôle
parlementaire c'est de droit mais la
séquence est complètement différent on a
mis en place un dispositif et il va
falloir il travaillait de façon étroite
qui est une commission en fait de
surveillance une commission denquête la
commission des lois deviennent
commission denquête avec le un travail
de contrôle des administrations qui se
prononce sous serment
donc on est dans un dans un dispositif
qui nous permet d'avoir une analyse un
suivi en aval en amont et ensuite
donc ça c'est la première des choses et
je moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on ait
un projet de loi constitutionnelle qui
soit en train de pondre plus parce
qu'ils soient à l'article non parce que
moi je suis je suis pas d'accord avec
vous je considère que lorsqu'on est hors
du droit commun
lorsqu'on est dans des dispositions où
les libertés individuelles peuvent être
mises en question
eh bien il faut identifier 30 secondes à
ce jour là la constitution s'appliquera
même plus ne fait pas une vraie garantie
on sait très bien effectivement bp
devrait nous devant donner ce message
mais que nous que de l'état d'urgence
est un dispositif dérogatoire qui
piquait est exceptionnel et coûteux les
procédés les français aujourd'hui elle
veut qu'ils ont bien compris on a plus
administrative beaucoup plus important
que le pouvoir judiciaire dont il faut
absolument que l'enfant identifiés dans
la constitution
ça c'est mon point de vue à la fois
juridique et politique s'agissant de la
prorogation était lobé lance le
parlement la bio projet mais les mots
ces deux là c'est différent la
prorogation d'état d'urgence
oui bien sûr il faut aller je vous
interromps je vous interromps frappé ce
qu'on va faire une pause pour voir
l'actualité à la mi journée
or en bourgogne on va jeter un coup
d'oeil donc avec le flash régional qui
est présenté ce midi par arnaud lefebvre
on se retrouve juste après